Now that you have completed your
summary section, let's move forward and
create your experience section.
Whether it's a full time position or
an intern-ship, you can include it here.
Similar to the ways you fill in your
resume, you should utilize bullet
point statements to convey your
achievements at each position.
Bullet statements begin with action
verbs and should be one to one and
a half lines long, focus and
detail in your achievements and
not just your daily tasks.
Include concrete details
with these statements.
Numerical evidence of
contributions is a plus.
Remember, bullet statements
are simplified phrases.
So avoid using excessive pronouns or
small words.
Finally, aim for a maximum of
four bullet points per section.
Mention your previous job titles,
organizations, and
the time you served at each role.
Add thanks to projects,
videos, photos, and
anything else that relates to your
experience, but be selective.
If you worked at a position many years
ago that isn't relevant any more,
you don't have to list it.
Sometimes, less is more.